Eigentlich Ist Ja alles ganz Klar die spiralarme von Galaxien Bewegen Sich zu Schnell Eigentlich MüSsten sie wenn man sich die
materie Ansieht die sie enthalten Viel Langsamer Um das Zentrum der Galaxien Kreisen Als sie es tun und das Ist
ÜBerall Im universum so die einzige erklärung von der Nahezu alle physiker Ausgehen es gibt mehr Als die sichtbare materie
die Dunkle materie Aber Bisher wurde sie einfach Nicht Gefunden Niemand Hat Irgendetwas
Entdeckt Dass sie sein Könnte sie versteckt Sich Einfach Könnte sie vielleicht gar Nicht Existieren Jetzt Sind Klicks Um science-fiction Herzlich Willkommen
Schon 1983 stellte der israelische physiker morde heim in Rom eine umstrittene theorie auf Gibt es Vielleicht gar Keine Dunkle materie
er wusste noch Nichts von der Jahrzehntelangen Vergeblichen suche Nach der Dunkle materie Bis zum heutigen tage Ist Kein
Teilchen der Dunklen materie Gefunden Worden Dabei sollte der großteil des Universums Oder Ein
Erheblicher teil des Universums Aus Dunkler materie Bestehen
23 prozent des Universums Wären Dunkle materie
4,6 prozent die uns bekannte materie und 72% Dunkle energie Wenn aber die fünffache menge Verglichen mit der
Bekannten materie Dunkle materie Werden das Müssen sie doch irgendwie
Aufzuspüren Sein Aber Pustekuchen
Es ist Nicht das geringste zu Finden Aber Wo Versteckt sie sich nur Oder tut sie das gar Nicht nur Daheim hatte
1983 Eine andere idee und sie Ist verblüffend einleuchten Warum Erzähle ich Gleich Erstmal die idee er hat das newtons
gravitationsgesetz bei Kleinen beschleunigungen modifiziert und Ausprobiert Was passiert Wenn er eine neue konstante Einführt
0 heißt sie und es ist Wirklich Ziemlich Beeindruckend was Dann passiert seine idee nennt Sich
modifizierte newtonsche
Dynamik Kurz nd Mond und Kommt bei Extrem Kleinen Beschleunigung Durch die
Gravitation zum Tragen wie sie eben in den äußeren Armen Einer Galaxie
Existiert Das frappierende er hat Sich Viele Galaxien Angesehen und Kann immer Wieder Auf den gleichen Wert Für 1 0
1,2 mal 10 hoch Minus Zehn
meter Pro Sekunde Im quadrat also ein immens Kleiner Wert 10 stellen Hinter Dem Komma die App Beschleunigung zum Vergleich liegt bei
9,81 meter Pro Sekunde Im quadrat Riesig Dagegen Ab diesem Wert also Ab Dem Kleinen Nullwert und das gilt für alle
achtung alle Galaxien Bleibt die rotationsgeschwindigkeit
Um das zentrum der Galaxien gleich immer und dazu und das macht diese theorie für die Physik so interessant Ist sie
Elegant Den Mond Ermöglicht es die materien den Galaxien hilfsweise über das abgestrahlte Licht zu Bestimmen und damit die
rotationsgeschwindigkeit
Auszurechnen und es Stimmt
Ich sehe Mir eine galaxie an und weiß wie sie sich Bewegt Das Heißt diese theorie Ist ganz einfach Durch die
Beobachtete rotationsgeschwindigkeit der Galaxien Im weltraum Belegt es Gibt nur Einen Haken Warum Ist Das so baum Gibt es diese konstante
es gibt keine erklärung Aber Eigentlich gilt Das Ja auch für die dunkle materie Ist gibt Keinen Beweis
und die Dunkle materie die für Eine Galaxie Angenommen Wird Ist bei weitem Nicht so einfach zu Bestimmen wie mond die rotationsgeschwindigkeit
Ermittelt Aber es gibt Eine Galaxie die ganz Klar Nicht Durch Mondt Erklärt Werden Kann Dass bullet Cluster Eigentlich Sind es zwei
Galaxien der mal Kollidiert Sind Aber und das Ist echt Verrückt Auch die theorie der Dunkle materie Funktioniert Hier Nicht richtig
Der letzte astronomen der universität Basel Oliver müller hat in einem Beitrag für science Blog Jetzt Viele andere Beispiele von lange
Angenommenen Irrtümern der Wissenschaft Angeführt Hat Nec
Hielten Sich diese Theorien wie sie einfach Nicht mehr zu Halten Waren Dabei Ist Wichtig Festzustellen Dass die Dunkle materie Bisher nur eine
Hypothese Ist sie Ist Zwar Als Sehr Wahrscheinlich in der für sie akzeptiert Aber
noch wurde Keinerlei Beweis Gefunden müller Erinnert an die theorie der alten Griechen Wonach Sich die planeten Um die erde Drehten
Jede Beobachtung Führte allerdings Dazu Dass die theorie Nicht mehr so ganz passte und mit Jeder Beobachtungen Wurden neue Hilfs Hypothesen Aufgestellt
Irgendwann Passt Aber gar Nichts mehr und eine neue Erkenntnis Brach Sich Bahn
Ja die planeten Kreist Um die sonne oder Im 19 Jahrhundert wurde der planet Vulkan Erfunden Um die
Bewegungen von Merkur Um die sonne zu Erklären die Wissenschaft
Besteht Aus Versuch und irrtum und nur wenn eine hypothese Bestätigt Wird Ist sie war und bei der dunkle materie gibt es noch keine Bestätigung
wer weiß Vielleicht Wird sie es nie geben weil die dunkle materie Nicht Existiert und vielleicht Ist es Dann doch
mode ich halte euch Dazu
Auf Jeden Fall Auf Dem Laufen Wenn ihr Kein video zur Dunkle materie Oder Mond Verpassen Wollt Dann Drückt Mir hier ein Aber Aufs Auge
und Vergesst Nicht Den
Auf die glocke damit er Nichts Verpasst Hier geht es Weiter Mit neue erkenntnisse zur Dunklen materie
Dann Gibt es Wieder in diensten für die Dunkle materie
Draufklicken es bleibt Spannend also Bis Dann
Bleibt Dran